la séance est ouverte le compte-rendu
analytique de la précédente séance a été
distribuée il n'y a pas d'observation je
n'en vois pas le procès-verbal est
adopté sous les réserves d'usage
chers collègues j'ai le regret de vous
faire part du décès de notre ancien
collègue Pierre Martin qui fut sénateur
de la somme de 1995 à 2014
l'ordre du jour appelle l'examen de deux
projets de loi tenant à autoriser la
ratification ou l'approbation de
convention internationale pour ces deux
projets de loi la Conférence des
Présidents a retenu la procédure
d'examens simplifiée je vais donc les
mettre successivement aux voix
je mets au bois le texte adopté par la
commission sur le projet de loi adopté
par l'Assemblée nationale après
engagement de la procédure accélérée
autorisant la ratification de la
résolution relative aux amendements de à
la convention du 6 mars 1948 portant
création de l'Organisation maritime
internationale la commission des
affaires étrangères est favorable à
l'adoption de ce texte qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient le projet
de loi est adopté définitivement
je mets au bois le texte adopté par la
commission sur le projet de loi adopté
par l'Assemblée nationale après
engagement de la procédure accélérée
autorisant l'approbation du premier
amendement à la Convention adoptée à
ESPO le 25 février sur l'évaluation de
l'impact le 25 février 1991 pardon sur
l'évaluation de l'impact sur
l'environnement dans leurs incontextes
trans frontières la commission des
affaires étrangères est favorable à
l'adoption de ce texte qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient le projet
de loi est définitivement adopté
l'ordre du jour appelle l'examen des
conclusions de la commission
mixparitaire chargée d'élaborer un texte
sur les dispositions restant en
discussion du projet de loi relatif à la
programmation militaire pour les années
2024 à 2030 et portant diverses
dispositions intéressants la défense la
parole est à Monsieur Christian Cambon
rapporteur pour le Sénat de la
commission mixeur pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
c'est le président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues
nos soldats font leurs devoirs de façon
admirable jour après jour nuit après
nuit et je tiens ici à le rendre
anommage solennel car en vérité c'est
bien pour eux que nous sommes tous
réunis ce matin pour le gouvernement
faire son devoir c'était donner à nos
armées les moyens d'accomplir leur
mission
cette LPM est marquée par une remontée
très conséquente des crédits et des
effectifs que nous saluons monsieur le
ministre nous vous en donnons acte et
nous vous remercions pour la part
importante que vous avez pris bien
évidemment tout au long de cette
procédure pour le Parlement faire son
devoir c'était bien sûr soutenir
l'effort inscrits dans cette LPM en lui
donnant l'assise démocratique la plus
large possible mais c'était aussi c'est
notre rôle dissiper un certain nombre de
zones de flou qui pouvait exister dans
le projet initial du gouvernement et
c'était enfin porté notre profonde que
les circonstances justifient de porter
au meilleur niveau possible notre effort
de défense pour atteindre ces objectifs
le Sénat a mené un travail préparatoire
approfondi sur plusieurs mois et je
souhaite en ces instants salut et tous
nos collègues de la Commission de la
façon dont la défense et des forces
armées qui se sont engagés dans cet
effort et je veux aussi saluer nos deux
rapporteurs pour avis des commissions
des finances que les Dominique de neige
et de la commission des lois c'est
important travail préparatoire nous a
permis de construire un consensus très
large des groupes politiques et de
préparer au mieux nos échanges avec
vous-même monsieur le ministre puis avec
l'Assemblée nationale je voudrais en cet
instant rendre aussi hommage au travail
de nos collègues députés et notamment au
président Thomas gassillou et au
rapporteur Jean-Michel Jacques avec qui
nous avons eu des échanges
particulièrement respectueux et
constructif
monsieur le ministre je vous remercie
également ainsi que la première ministre
pour votre grande disponibilité dans les
laboration de la LPM et singulièrement
la première ministre pour avoir fait les
efforts en dans la dernière longueur qui
ont permis de débloquer bien des
échanges ces échanges ils ont été francs
parfois direct mais je crois qu'ils ont
éclairé ce texte et permis de dégager
une convergence sur l'essentiel dans un
esprit républicain c'est dans cet esprit
constructif mais exigeant que le Sénat a
travaillé enrichir le projet de loi de
programmation militaire je veux en
rappeler brièvement les trois axes
principaux le premier axe c'était bien
sûr et c'est la marque du Sénat c'était
l'amélioration de la trajectoire
financière le Sénat a estimé en effet
que à la fois le contexte géopolitique
actuel et la situation et les
difficultés que nos armées rencontrent
parfois dans l'entraînement tout ceci
nécessitait de remonter en puissance le
plus rapidement possible je suis heureux
que nous ayons pu être entendus ce sont
en effet 2 milliards 300 millions
d'euros supp qui seront inscrits sur les
quatre années 2024 à 2027 le second axe
est essentiel tout autant car il
conditionne l'exécution de la LPM c'est
le contrôle parlementaire le Sénat a
levé une ambiguïté en précisant que
l'actualisation de la LPM ne pourrait se
faire que par la loi c'est un point
auquel nous tenions particulièrement
depuis l'épisode de l'actualisation de
2021 nous avons obtenu par ailleurs une
amélioration de l'information du
Parlement dans le domaine capacitaire et
nous avons étendu les compétences de la
délégation parlementaire au
renseignement au sujet d'actualité sur
les questions de renseignement nous
avons accepté de renoncer à notre
dispositif sur le contrôle exercé par la
cnctr mais en contrepartie de ce geste
monsieur le ministre nous attendons que
vous nous précisiez un certain nombre de
direction et que vous travaillez avec
nous sur cette question compliquée la
commission mix paritaire a également
créé une commission parlementaire
d'évaluation de la politique
d'exportation d'armes c'est un élément
très important car il est tout à fait
nouveau dans le paysage de l'exportation
des armes dont on connaît le poids
économique dans notre pays et là il y a
un geste qu'il convient de saluer
troisième axe enfin qui nous semble
essentiel celui du financement des
entreprises de défense conscient des
difficultés techniques du dispositif
initial de livret d'épargne souveraineté
nous avons trouvé avec les députés une
solution de compromis consistante à
affecter une partie de la ressource
collectée au titre du livre a vers les
entreprises de la défense notamment et
j'allais dire plus particulièrement les
petits et moyennes entreprises qui sont
les plus confrontées à la frilosité de
certains établissements bancaires nous
attendons là aussi votre soutien c'est
une première étape et il faudra aller
plus loin avant de conclure je voudrais
à nouveau remercier tous nos
collectionneurs et députés qui ont
participé à des débats intenses parfois
passionnés mais les enjeux de ce texte
le méritaient ce processus long et
complexe nous permet d'aboutir à une loi
de programmation que nos armées
attendaient et dont toute notre nation a
besoin pour sa sécurité et sa
souveraineté aussi mes chers collègues
je vous invite à adopter les conclusions
de la commission mixte paritaire je vous
remercie merci monsieur le président
la parole est à Monsieur Sébastien
Lecornu ministre des Armées
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président de la commission des affaires
étrangères de la défense et des forces
armées et rapporteur de la commission
mixte paritaire
messieurs les rapporteurs mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs je tenais à
commencer à mon tour mon propos par là
où je l'avais terminé lors de mon
intervention discussion générale et
surtout que je quitte à l'instant
l'ensemble des familles des tuées morts
pour le service de la nation mort pour
le service de la République est mort
pour la France qui était rassemblés
autour de nous à Brienne ce matin en
ayant une pensée pour celles et ceux
vous avez accueillir cet après-midi dans
le cadre d'une visite plus globale et
donc je vais avoir une pensée pour les
femmes et les hommes qui ont fait le
choix de l'engagement au sein de nos
forces armées ainsi qu'aux nombreux
civils de la défense qui servent au
quotidien et c'est à eux que nous devons
penser alors que ce matin le Sénat au
lendemain de l'assemblée nationale hier
s'apprête à se prononcer sur ce projet
de loi de programmation militaire pour
les années de 2024 à 2030 c'est un
moment important pour nos armées lorsque
tous les cinq six ou parfois sept ans le
Parlement discute et vote un projet de
loi de programme pour fixer un cap à
notre défense nationale définir les
effets militaires que nous souhaitons
produire face au menaces qui pèsent sur
le pays détailler les missions qui
peuvent être confiées à nos armées et
bien entendu les moyens que nous leur
allons en lien avec nos capacités
industrielles c'est aussi un moment
important pour la nation qui prend la
mesure du rôle fondamental que joue nos
militaires quelques heures de notre 14
juillet pour garantir notre sécurité
notre souveraineté et en fin de compte
peut-être plus simplement notre
prospérité c'est enfin un moment
important pour les puissances étrangères
qui nous observent qu'il s'agisse de
pays alliés mais aussi de compétiteurs
et qui prennent acte de la puissance de
notre République de notre nation pour
trouver dans le respect des règles
constitutionnelles qui encadrent les
compétences de chacun les voies et
moyens de répondre des sécuritaire qui
pèse sur notre pays alors que
l'Assemblée nationale a adopté hier à
une très large majorité des conclusions
de la commission mixte paritaire et sur
lesquels le Sénat se prononcera dans
quelques minutes je veux revenir sur les
éléments à mon tour monsieur le
Président qui ont permis je le crois que
l'examen de ce texte soit utile pour le
débat politique national sur un sujet
singulier avec une histoire française
singulière dans un moment mondial lui
aussi tout aussi singulier tout d'abord
si je forme le vœu que ce 15e projet de
loi de programmation militaire rencontre
le succès par le vote que vous ferez
dans quelques instants sur les
conclusions de la commission mix
paritaire je relève comme je l'avais
fait lors de la discussion générale que
les sujets militaires ne sont toujours
pas consensuels sur des sujets
fondamentaux dans la construction de
notre système de défense je m'avance
d'ailleurs un peu en admettant que ces
projets de loi de programmation auraient
tous été voté à chaque fois puisque sur
les 14 précédents projets de notre
programmation militaire depuis 1960
pas seul n'a pas été voté par le
Parlement en 1992 et d'ailleurs dans une
autre histoire entre le général de
Gaulle et cette maison le Sénat
n'avait-il pas lui-même rejeté dans le
préalable la première loi de
programmation militaire en 1960 c'est
rappel historique montre que ces sujets
de défense sont bien entendu au sens
noble du terme des sujets politiques
avec des modèles et des visions qui
peuvent s'affronter s'agissant de nos
alliances notamment du rôle et de la
place de notre dissuasion nucléaire et
même sur la doctrine d'emploi de nos
forces armées en réponse à des menaces
dans les contours ne sont pas toujours
pleinement partagés par toutes et
partout je me nomme d'avoir pu mener ces
débats avec l'ensemble des
parlementaires des deux chambres au
cours de l'examen de ce texte en
apportant aux françaises et aux Français
un éclairage salutaire sur ce que chaque
groupe politique représentait au sein
des deux hémicycles avec des différences
évidemment notables propose pour nos
armées les sujets de débats n'ont pas
manqué la force des convictions et des
arguments non plus il faut s'en réjouir
il n'a rien eu de médiocre le vote du
Sénat en première lecture parce que un
public a été clair il a permis de voir
que malgré quelques divergences mineures
nous étions sur le fond en très grande
majorité convaincue par les fondamentaux
du modèle d'armée voulue par le
président de la République mais Free
notre héritage depuis les années 60 et
présenté dans cette loi toutefois
parfois mais davantage à l'Assemblée
nationale le débat n'a pas occulté des
visions du monde et donc de notre
défense qui sont profondément je le
crois divergente et peut-être même
encore durablement irréconciliables
entre elles l'examen du texte a montré
que certaines sensibilités politiques
ont dépit de quelques clarifications
inédites et bienvenue encore hier
après-midi lors de la discussion
générale dans les explications de vote
de certains groupes avancent toujours
néanmoins dans une forme de flou
notamment sur le modèle d'alliance avec
nos partenaires européens mais aussi
nord-atlantique ou sur leur position
définitive et sans ambiguïté sur et sur
l'efficacité de la dissuasion nucléaire
cet examen parlementaire nous a permis
d'entendre les critiques faites et
certaines je le dis ici solennellement
sont à prendre et à entendre à prendre
en compte et entendre naturellement sur
le fonctionnement du modèle français
actuel pour autant je le crois les
débats n'ont pas toujours fait émerger
de contre-propositions crédible et
réaliste à ce modèle sur des sujets
pourtant aussi essentiels que les
alliances militaires bilatérales comme
multilatérale avec bien entendu la
question de notre place et notre rôle
dans l'OTAN mais aussi du bilan objectif
de ce qui a été fait par nos armées ces
dernières années en Afrique et de la
posture à adopter de manière courageuse
et pragmatique dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme et nous aurons l'occasion d'y
revenir la question des coopérations
industrielles avec nos partenaires a été
largement débattus ce qui a permis de
réaffirmer la ligne de conduite de ce
gouvernement et qui je le crois a trouvé
au fond à consensus bienvenue c'est à
dire de faire toujours primer faut-il le
rappeler l'intérêt de la France en ce
qui concerne les choix que nous faisons
avec nous continuerons de faire je me
suis donc engagé monsieur le Président
Cambon à revenir devant le Parlement à
chaque fois que nous nous engagerons
dans une nouvelle phase de coopération
sur les programmes comme le SCAF ou le
mgcs je le ferai je suis persuadé que
cela permettra d'objectiver les critères
de manière rationnelle et les paramètres
là aussi de manière tout aussi
rationnelle je l'espère sur lesquels les
décisions doivent être prises pour
défendre l'intérêt général et l'intérêt
de notre modèle si elle Assemblée
nationale nous avons pu avoir un débat
sérieux et approfondi sur notre
dissuasion je peux peut-être regretter
pour améliorer la suite que nous n'ayons
pas suffisamment pris le temps de se
débat ici même et dont je voulais
m'engager près de vous monsieur le
Président comme je l'ai fait en privé à
vous redire ma disponibilité si vous
souhaitez aussi tenir ces discussions
sur la dissuasion nucléaire on ne peut
pas dire que d'un côté c'est la clé de
voûte et en même temps refuse le débat
donc là je pense aussi que nous pourrons
le refaire dans le cadre évidemment d'un
certain nombre de travaux que la
commission ou les groupes politiques
choisiront
évidemment de tenir alors l'adhésion en
grande majorité des groupes politiques
ici du Sénat sur le modèle d'armée au
fond c'est que les débats ici se sont
concentrés se sont focalisés en tout cas
sur de nombreuses considérations
budgétaires et sur des sous-jacents plus
financiers la trajectoire de la LPM en
cela c'était peut-être aussi une des
différenciations bicamérale et j'ai donc
effectivement entendu la volonté
partagée sur de nombreux bancs que les
forces financiers puissent être
amplifiés en début de période j'y
reviendrai dans un instant mais je
souhaite aussi revenir en préalable sur
d'autres sujets qui sont déterminants il
me semble que il mérite aussi un débat
qui dépasseront désormais les murs du
Parlement pour emmener la Nation toute
entière et nos concitoyens sur la
compréhension de ce modèle d'armée à
l'histoire singulière et qui objectifent
les menaces qui pèsent sur la France ce
n'est pas tant d'un débat entre expert
que dont nous avons besoin qu'un débat
plus national désormais et peut-être
même populaire
ton corps nous aurons l'occasion d'y
revenir mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs en tout état de cause je pense
pouvoir affirmer dans le respect de la
séparation des pouvoirs et du rôle que
nous constituants ont donné à chacun en
matière de défense nationale que le
Parlement a trouvé toute sa place dans
ce débat et qu'il en sort je crois
renforcer les dispositions adoptées
viendront consolider le contrôle du
Parlement sur l'exécution et
l'actualisation de cette programmation
notamment chaque année en amont de
l'examen des projets de loi de finances
qui restent on le sait monsieur le
rapporteur de Munich delène les
véritables actes parlementaires pour
engager concrètement les crédits pour
nos armées ce renforcement du contrôle
parlementaire assez historique au fond
depuis le début de la cinquième
république permettra aux deux chambres
de tenir un rôle essentiel dans la
poursuite de la montée en puissance de
nos armées et dans les orientations
qu'il faudra leur donner et je me
réjouis de ses avancées c'est un signal
important vous voyez à ceux qui doutent
de la vitalité de notre modèle
démocratique et nos institutions il
permettra aussi au Parlement de
s'assurer que les choix fait en 2023
seront toujours adapté à l'évolution des
menaces au long de la période de
programmation trop souvent dans le passé
l'observance strict pour ne pas dire
parfois scolaire de la programmation
nous a conduit à prendre des retards ou
à prendre des décisions parfois de
bonnes décisions mais trop tardivement
je ne reviendrai pas sur le débat que
nous avons eu sur les drones il faut en
tirer des conclusions désormais pour
l'avenir dans le respect des grands
principes de la Cinquième République il
est évident que le moment dans lequel
nous trouvons permet au Parlement de
trouver sa place dans notre politique de
défense et les débats que nous avons eu
nous oblige d'ores et déjà pour l'avenir
dans cette réactivité et dans cette
manière de mettre à jour la
programmation en lien avec les
parlementaires enfin le succès de la
reprogrammation militaire que je
l'espère votre définitivement dans un
instant tiens tu as une forme de
responsabilité que chacun a su prendre
pour définir une trajectoire budgétaire
vous y êtes revenu monsieur le Président
Cambon au service d'une ambition
militaire documentée et crédible c'est à
dire de financer des capacités d'agir
concrètes afin d'as la défense nous
intérêts et de répondre aux menaces
actuelles mais aussi et surtout futures
dans tous les espaces de conflictualité
c'est là au fond le grand chantier de
transformation que enclenche est-elle PM
les débats ont été longs et nombreux
pour aboutir au compromis trouver lundi
dernier au commission mixte paritaire
afin d'assurer à nos militaires les
moyens d'émissions tous leurs confions
ce compromis permet je le pense de
répondre à l'indispensable besoin de
cohérence pour notre modèle l'armée
d'emploi c'est-à-dire de mieux équiper
de mieux former de mieux soutenir de
plus recruter fidéliser et de plus
entraîner nos forces vous êtes revenu
nombreuses reprises sur ce point tout en
nous assurant la soutenabilité de la
trajectoire pour nos finances publiques
dans la durée à ce titre devant le Sénat
je tiens à adresser mais plus sincères
remerciements au président Cambon avec
lequel le dialogue a toujours été
particulièrement franc et constructif et
je rajouterai en dehors de mon texte
particulièrement ferme tout autant que
fiable ce qui fait évidemment de la
discussion il y a quelque chose de
précieux et je vous en Suisse il y a
titre personnel particulièrement
reconnaissant le Parlement dans ce
compromis paritaire a souhaité que nous
mettions davantage de moyens au début de
la période sans pour autant ce qu'une
rue aucun sens j'y suis revenu de
nombreuses reprises alourdir la facture
globale des 400 milliards d'euros de
crédit budgétaires et changer la
programmation des 413 milliards d'euros
cette volonté a été largement portée par
les sénateurs de plusieurs groupes
politiques ici nous l'avons entendu et
donc nous sommes parvenus à cet accord
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs pour
conclure je ne considère pas cette toit
de programmation militaire comme un
aboutissement c'est le fruit de
l'engagement du président de la
République chef des armées qui depuis
son élection 2017 à garder intacte sa
volonté de permettre à notre modèle
militaire de se réparer puis de se
transformer tout cela avant même que
n'éclate la guerre en Ukraine ce vote ne
doit pas non plus acter la fin des
débats sur ces sujets militaires à un
débat plus national que j'évoquais il y
a un instant ça ajoute des débats et
travaux à tenir ici même sur différents
sujets clés pour la réussite de nos
objectifs
la réarticulation de notre stratégie en
Afrique impulsée par le chef de l'État
est un sujet sur lequel je reviendrai
régulièrement devant vous pour vous
rendre compte des différentes étapes que
nous franchirons et j'ai entendu aussi
l'appel porté par le sénateur Rachid
themal lors de la discussion générale au
nom de son groupe a approfondir nos
échanges sur l'OTAN la place de la
France dans cette alliance le bilan de
la réintégration du commandement intégré
les effets militaires recherchés le
périmètre de l'Alliance autant de sujets
sur lequel nous n'avons pas franchement
eu le temps de débattre vous aviez
souhaité dans un autre cadre un débat
sur l'Afrique peut-être est-ce que cela
qu'il faut le faire ou en commission en
tout cas je le crois c'est le moment de
tenir et de prendre le temps de le faire
et donc je voulais vous redire pour le
groupe socialiste à disponibilité à le
faire le contrôle démocratique aussi sur
nos services de renseignement a été un
sujet sur lequel il nous faudra
poursuivre les discussions tout comme
effectivement les questions liées aux
exportations d'armes tout en gardant
pour les services de renseignement à
l'esprit qui ne doit jamais comprendre
nos opérations ou entraîner une menace
pour la sécurité de nos agents sur le
terrain auquel je tiens ici à le rendre
un hommage particulier dans le cadre de
l'économie de guerre vous l'avez rappelé
dans votre propos de synthèse monsieur
le Président Cambon nous n'échapperons
pas à travailler collectivement sur le
financement des entreprises de la base
industrielle et technologique de défense
et plus particulièrement pour les PME et
les ETI le Parlement c'est largement en
paraître ce sujet c'est vous qui l'avez
fait largement monter et je crois que
c'est une bonne chose et nous devons en
suivant le poursuivre les réflexions de
manière très opérationnelle enfin sur
les sujets liés aux ressources humaines
à la fidélisation aux travaux sur la
grille indiciaire ou sur l'indemnitaire
au recrutement des militaires d'active
comme des réservistes là aussi tout
n'est affaire que d'art d'exécution et
donc là aussi il faudra associer le
Parlement à cette affaire je pense enfin
la remonter en puissance de nos armées
dans nos outre-mer pour assurer notre
souveraineté bien au-delà de l'Hexagone
nous la devons à nos concitoyens
ultramarins de la devons à tout à chacun
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
veux à titre plus personnel vous dire
enfin l'honneur qui fut le mien de
défendre ce projet loi de programmation
militaire devant vous humblement
respectueusement en écoutant en
répondant de manière engagée mais vous
me connaissez désormais aux arguments
qui ont été développés par chaque groupe
politique représenté sur ses bancs je
crois qu'on se livrant à cet exercice
sans tabou avec beaucoup de liberté
intellectuelle nous avons chacun permis
de renforcer le projet de défense que
nous portons pour la nation nous avons
livré aux femmes et aux hommes qui
servent au quotidien sous l'uniforme et
plus largement à l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens à débat à la hauteur des
défis qu'ils auront à relever demain
pour notre sécurité notre souveraineté
sans oublier que ces décisions
s'inscrivent dans nos traditions en lien
avec notre mémoire nationale et le lien
qui unit nos armées d'aujourd'hui avec
nos anciens combattants tout comme avec
notre jeunesse plus encore nous avons
fait la démonstration collective que le
débat démocratique et la solution qui
permet à une nation de s'armer face aux
menaces qui la vise qu'en tant de nos
compétiteurs vantent les mérites de
modèles autoritaires je forme le mieux
veut que ce combat des idées qui fait la
force de notre République qui a permis
d'aboutir aux textes qui est soumis à
vos votes ce matin féconde pour les 7
prochaines années et pour longtemps
encore le succès de nos armes et la
grandeur de la France je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre
je rappelle qu'en application de
l'article 42 alinéa 12 du règlement le
Sénat statut par un seul vote sur
l'ensemble du texte nous passons aux
explications de vote des groupes à
raison d'un orateur par groupe le
premier Jean-Noël Guérini pour le groupe
RDSE pour 5 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense des forces armées mes chers
collègues
je ne vais pas ici revenir sur les
résultats du vote qui a permis
l'adoption de ce test qui a fait l'objet
d'une commission Miss paritaire
conclusive ce lundi toutefois malgré les
difficiles négociations en amont de
cette dite CMP je souhaite garder en
mémoire les 314 voies exprimées en
faveur de cette programmation qui est et
j'en suis certain au diapason des
attentes de la nation et de nos
militaires
ce résultat
révèle le Conseil suisse républicain
guidant le vote des crédits de l'armée
c'est le vent à 413 milliards personne
n'a jamais remis en cause l'impérieuse
des sociétés d'une armée performante en
capacité de faire face aux nouvelles
menaces et de répondre à ces engagements
internationaux tant au niveau européen
au niveau de l'OTAN mais il nous
appartient désormais de veiller à
l'avenir au respect des engagements pris
et nous devrons soyons en convaincus
exercés une attention de tous les
instants sur l'exécution de cette
programmation
je regrette que la CMP est amputée
certaines mesures du test du Sénat
excité vous l'avez
vous en avez parlé monsieur le ministre
des créations d'une commission de
vérification des exportations d'armement
au sein de la délégation parlementaire
au renseignement nous aurons un lieu et
place une simple commission
parlementaire d'évaluation de la
politique
d'exportation au contour plus ou moins
floues excite la création de livrer
souveraineté en soutien dans le cas de
la promotion du lien fort nation armée
destinée au financement de l'industrie
de défense en complément de l'effort
budgétaire
la création d'un livret souveraineté ne
serait pas selon les dires du ministère
des Finances de nature à améliorer le
financement de la basse industrielle
technologique de la défense
en revanche nous proposer un guise de
compensation en pleine crise du logement
alors que les Français peinent accéder à
des logements loyers modérés de
déshabiller une partie des fonds
collectés destinés justement au logement
social dans le cas du livret A jeudi
bravo et surtout pas merci
excite la conditionnalité du recueil de
données de l'impie au contrôle de la
Commission nationale de contrôle des
techniques de renseignements excité des
amendements sénatoriaux en faveur de
l'augmentation des sites de matériel 153
d'indilles 2030
17 engins de reconnaissance et de
combats Jaguar 325 blindés légers
toutefois je tiens à saluer le compromis
favorable aux positions du Sénat sur la
trajectoire budgétaire notre commission
souhaitait garantir une progression des
crédits rythmée et réguliers ces choses
faites un ajustement de la trajectoire
opposant sur une hausse de 3,3 milliards
d'euros en 2024 puis en 2025 32 en 2026
et
2027 et enfin 3 milliards et demi
jusqu'en 2030 je me permets ici
maintenant de paraphraser des propos du
président Cambon en déclarant que ce
compromis répond à l'effet
d'accélération attendue par nos armées
soit 47 milliards d'euros en 2024 pour
atteindre 67 milliards d'euros en 2030
notons que la CN à confirmer le principe
d'une meilleure information du Parlement
sur le soutien d'Ukraine ainsi que des
mesures mémorielles pendant
l'amélioration des mesures de réparation
et de reconnaissance notamment
n'assouplissement des critères de
bénéfice mort pour la France malgré
monsieur le ministre des réserves qui
persistent et qu'il était nécessaire de
rappeler le groupe RD se habitait par le
devoir et le sens des responsabilités
estiment que la LPM n'est pas seulement
un test et Grenant une farandole de
chiffres mais vise à construire à
consolider et à défendre nos armées et
dans ces conditions le groupe RDS votra
en faveur de ce test je vous remercie
merci chers collègues
la parole est à Monsieur Pascal Alizard
pour le groupe les républicains pour 5
minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président
rapporteur mes chers collègues en tant
que législateur nous savons que toutes
les lois sont importantes mais il arrive
que certaines soient plus décisives que
d'autres la loi de programmation
militaire indéniablement appartient à
cette seconde catégorie si ce n'est pas
une loi comme les autres c'est parce
qu'elle touche à l'essentiel au
fondamental elle est un socle sur lequel
repose la vocation première de l'État
protéger la France et les Français
le débat de ce jour vient alors une
séquence de 7 mois consacrée par le
Sénat à l'étude de la loi de
programmation militaire
2024-2030 notre commission des affaires
étrangères de la défense et des forces
armées les commissions des lois et des
Finances saisies pour avis on devrait
pour enrichir le projet du gouvernement
le nombre et la diversité des auditions
en témoignent de nombreux amendements
auxquels les sénateurs les républicains
ont contribué ont été adoptés en
commission comme en séance je le pense
nous sommes allés au fond des choses
animées par l'idée de produire un texte
crédible opérationnel pour les armées
françaises qui sont très sollicités sur
le territoire national et en OPEX depuis
plusieurs années
l'accord trouvé en CMP sur un texte
commun qui ouvre la voie à une
promulgation rapide de cette LPM et donc
une bonne nouvelle et je crois que nous
serons d'accord sur ce point monsieur le
ministre
la plupart des orientations retenus au
Sénat et qui illustre nos préoccupations
ont été conservées en CMP le Sénat
obtenu que l'effort soit réhaussée dès
l'année prochaine et au total ce sont 2
milliards 3 d'euros supplémentaires qui
pourront être mobilisés d'ici 2027 c'est
à nos yeux fondamental et c'était bien
le minimum pour garantir la cohérence de
la programmation militaire face aux
menaces grandissantes mais aussi face à
l'inflation parce que dans le contexte
que nous connaissons finalement dépenser
un peu plus vite est une manière de
faire des économies sur l'ensemble de la
période
par ailleurs le renforcement des moyens
de contrôle du Parlement et du lien
d'armée nation sont aussi des avancées
notables dont il faut se féliciter la
défense et l'affaire de tous en ce qui
concerne l'abbitd les dispositions
adoptées prennent en compte les
difficultés de financement des
entreprises de la défense notamment les
PME les ETI ainsi que la multiplication
des contraintes normatives qui
s'appliquent ou qui vont s'appliquer sur
ce secteur nous disposons d'entreprises
innovantes réparties sur tout le
territoire de compétences rares et longs
à acquérir d'un outil industriel
performant il faut les préserver pour ne
pas finir comme nombre de nos voisins en
Europe en client captif de l'industrie
américaine c'est d'ailleurs aussi
l'avenir de l'abbéit des européennes qui
se joue la création d'un environnement
plus favorable pour les banques et les
investisseurs se met progressivement en
place ainsi l'affectation d'une partie
des ressources collectées dans le cadre
du livret A vers les entreprises de la
défense est une étape importante et
rendez-vous est pris dans trois ans pour
un premier bilan
l'amélioration de la visibilité sur
l'évolution des commandes est livraisons
de matériel permettra aussi aux
entreprises d'assurer la continuité
industrielle il reste que le nouvel
ordre mondial qui émerge face à la
pression accrue des compétiteurs
stratégiques la France doit pouvoir
conserver un rôle de premier plan et
disposer des moyens en conséquence la
modernisation de la dissuasion qui vient
d'être actée constitue
une garantie non négligeable les
conflits de haute intensité ou hybrides
qui se dessine requarrons nous le savons
plus de masse et d'agilité et requeront
aussi de nouveaux efforts budgétaires
mais chers collègues à défaut d'avoir pu
faire plus je crois que le Sénat a
contribué à faire mieux nous avons
amélioré significativement la
proposition du Gouvernement sur nombre
de ses points essentiels c'est le rôle
du débat parlementaire c'est pourquoi le
groupe LR votera donc cette LPM j'alon
important sur le chemin de la
restauration des armes de la France
enfin mes chers collègues il nous
reviendra de demeurer vigilants sur
l'exécution de cette LPM dans les futurs
loi de finances cette exigence forte
nous la devons aux françaises et aux
Français et en particulier à toutes
celles à tous ceux qui s'engagent pour
servir et défendre notre pays à la
veille de la fête nationale du 14
juillet en cette fin d'examen de la LPM
nous avons une pensée fraternelle et
respectueuse pour eux je vous remercie
merci chers collègues
la parole était Monsieur Emmanuel Capu
pour le groupe les indépendants pour 5
minutes
monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues
Foch disait qu'un homme s'en mémoire est
un homme sans vie un peuple sans mémoire
est un peuple sans avenir la France elle
n'a jamais oublié que la sécurité n'est
pas donnée mais qu'elle doit être
acquise
nombre de nos partenaires ont refusé de
croire qu'une prospérité sans défense ne
protège pas des agressions
l'invasion russe de l'Ukraine marque la
fin des îles lusions et le début d'un
réveil douloureux pour beaucoup de
repères
la France et ses partenaires doivent
désormais faire face à des menaces de
haute intensité
à moins de 3000 km de Paris deux armées
modernes s'affrontent la guerre est de
retour sur notre continent son intensité
doit nous alarmer
le niveau des pertes de ce conflit est
effrayant 300 000 soldats auraient été
mis hors de combat 100 000 Ukrainiens
200 000 russes
un autre chiffre permet de souligner le
changement de paradigme la Russie a
perdu 2000 chars en Ukraine la France
n'en dispose au total que de 200
durant des décennies l'armée française a
dû faire face à d'importants
restrictions budgétaires
malgré ces réductions les femmes et les
hommes de nos armées ont réussi à mener
à bien les missions toujours délicate
qui leur ont été confiés je veux rendre
hommage ici à leur engagement et à leur
courage et à leur professionnalisme
comme la fait le président Cambon tout à
l'heure je salue la mémoire de ceux qui
sont tombés pour la France trop nombreux
dans un monde de plus en plus instable
nous sommes désormais confrontés à des
menaces hybrides d'intensité variable et
maintenant d'État tout autant que
d'acteurs asymétriques avec cette
nouvelle LPM il nous faut déterminer
quel modèle d'armée assurera le mieux la
protection de notre pays et de ses
intérêts la guerre moderne de haute
intensité implique un durcissement des
unités ainsi que leur massification
ensemble nous avons fait le choix d'une
montée en gamme nos alliances et
singulièrement la coopération européenne
doivent nous permettre de satisfaire à
l'impératif de masse
après des heures de débat les deux
chambres du Parlement sont parvenus à
s'accorder sur un texte commun député
comme sénateur nous sommes conscients
tous de la nécessité d'accroître
significativement les moyens de nos
armées afin qu'elles puissent affronter
les menaces qui pèsent sur la France
la trajectoire financière a encore été
renforcé en CMP grâce au travail du
Sénat et à l'engagement du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre le contexte
géopolitique nous contraint à accélérer
le calendrier
plus que jamais nous devons veiller à
maintenir la crédibilité de la
dissuasion nucléaire elle est la clé de
voûte de notre architecture stratégique
il est absolument indispensable qu'elle
puisse continuer à remplir sa mission
à cet égard je salue la performance du
planeur hypervélose Vmax réalisé à la
fin du mois dernier cette étape
importante témoigne de notre
détermination à nous maintenir au plus
haut niveau capacitaire
pour y parvenir il faut veiller à la
bonne santé de notre base technologique
et industrielle de défense ces
entreprises ont besoin de commande
l'exportation est à cet égard également
essentiel pour être souverain les
Européens doivent acheter européens
nous nous réjouissons que l’épargne des
Français soit également mobilisée pour
soutenir l'effort de défense une
fraction du livret A sera désormais
consacré au financement des entreprises
de défense
aujourd'hui comme hier la patrie a
besoin de femmes et d'hommes pour la
défendre les effectifs de nos armées
devront être portées à 275 000
équivalentes en plein 2030 pour les
appuyer mais aussi pour faire vivre le
lien armée nation la LPM prévoit
d'accroître le nombre de réservistes à
80 000 environ à l'horizon 2030 ces
mesures présentent évidemment un coût
élevé pour les finances publiques
l'État pourrait être efficace dans la
police et la justice il ne s'occupait
pas de mille préoccupations accessoires
cette considération de Frédéric Bastiat
vaut également pour la défense de la
nation
pour que l'État puisse être le plus
efficace dans ces missions régaliennes
il est indispensable de réduire ses
autres dépenses ces 1000 autres
préoccupations accessoires nous devrons
donc y veiller mes chers collègues le
groupe Les Indépendants votera en tout
état de cause en faveur de l'adoption de
ce texte
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Monsieur au président Guillaume Gontard
pour le groupe écologiste solidarité
territoire pour 5 minutes
monsieur le monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président rapporteur nous examinons donc
les conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire les écologistes saluent les
progrès qui a connu le texte lors de son
examen parlementaire notamment les
modifications adoptées au Sénat et
retenue par la CMP nous saluons les
avancées obtenues en matière de contrôle
parlementaire sur tous les volets de
l'action de l'exécutif en matière de
défense qui permet de corriger quelque
peu incongruité démocratiques que
représente ce domaine réservé de
l'exécutif nous nous félicitons que le
Parlement se prononce sur la
réactualisation de la LPM en 2027 et de
l'obligation d'élaborer un livre blanc
pour préparer la prochaine LPM
nous regrettons en revanche que la CMP
est nettement amputé les missions de la
commission parlementaire dédiée
anciennement au contrôle désormais
uniquement à l'évaluation des
exportations d'armes par la France
dans la mouture finale elle n'a plus
aucun pouvoir de contrôle et
d'investigation c'est un être recul par
rapport à l'ambition du Sénat la France
manque une occasion de remplir enfin les
conditions du code de bonne conduite de
l'Union européenne
cet LPM demande un effort important à la
nation avec une augmentation du budget
des armées de près de 50% d'ici à 2030
et un effort global de plus de 118
milliards d'euros sur le reste de la
décennie donc 17 milliards par an en
moyenne sans financement spécifique
le président du Haut Conseil des
finances publiques souligne d'ailleurs
les incertitudes sur le financement
d'une partie de ressources extra
budgétaires ce qui n'est pas en mesure
de nous rassurer
nos inquiétudes demeurent à l'issue de
cette CMP votre gouvernement enfermé
dans son dogmatisme refuse de faire
contribuer les plus aisés à les formes
nationales et promet un retour du
déficit public sous les 3% d'ici la fin
du quinquennat nous ne savons toujours
pas comment vous allez financer cette
llpm les 118 milliards supplémentaires
de cette programmation militaire
viendront nécessairement amputé les
crédits d'autres politiques publiques
tout aussi essentielles ce n'est pas
acceptable à nos yeux les défis à
relever et en particulier le défi
climatique sont trop nombreux pour
laisser filer indéfiniment les dépenses
de défense le groupe écologiste souhaite
d'ailleurs que le gouvernement soit
aussi réactif et ambitieux pour assurer
la sécurité climatique que pour assurer
la sécurité militaire de la France
c'est là où le bât blesse malgré
l'ampleur de l'effort de la nation nous
constatons que les moyens humains et
capacités à des forces conventionnelles
en particulier de l'armée de terre reste
insuffisant cette programmation ne
répond que partiellement aux besoins de
l'armée de terre de son équipement et du
bien-être des soldats et de leur famille
nous ne sommes pas encore à l'armée à
hauteur d'hommes défendu par vos
prédécesseurs en effet la France
maintient un modèle d'armée globale
reposant sur une dissuasion très sur une
dissuasion nucléaire très coûteuse qui
ne correspond pas à sa puissance et à
ses moyens réels j'ai noté avec
satisfaction que vous souhaitiez ouvrir
le débat en ajoutant à ce modèle déjà
difficile à tenir de nouveaux espaces de
conflictualité le problème ne fait que
s'aggraver en refusant de faire des
choix et d’établir des priorités le
gouvernement expose le pays à un double
risque soit un échantillonnage de ses
moyens militaires soit une augmentation
une augmentation exponentielle des
dépenses militaires dans les prochaines
décennies
nous sommes convaincus que le modèle de
notre armée doit être rationalisé et
intégré dans une perspective de
coalition européenne l'Europe et
l'échelle pour retrouver la puissance à
laquelle la France aspire pour faire
face aux nouvelles menaces
géostratégiques comme pour mutualiser
les efforts engagés par les pays membres
pour leur sécurité sur tous ces sur
toutes ces questions malgré quelques
progrès dans le rapport annexé la LPM
reste peu disserté nous nous félicitons
cependant des progrès du texte
enregistrés à l'initiative des groupes
écologistes des deux chambres s'agissant
notamment de l'amélioration de
l'inclusivité et de la mixité de nos
armées s'agissant de l'affirmation de
quelques ambitions en matière de
transition énergétique du rappel de la
nécessité de tenir nos engagements
contractés dans le traité de non
prolifération militaires
plus largement nous saluons le travail
parlementaire sur ce texte et nous vous
remercions Monsieur le Ministre pour
votre attitude durant ces débats qui ont
été un exemple de co-construction
législative efficace nous savons
effectivement reconnaître quand il le
faut il y a un an nous étions en droit
de croire que tous les projets de loi de
la mandature sans majorité absolue
serait examinée de la sorte le groupe
écologiste est parfaitement conscient du
besoin impérieux de reconstituer nos
stocks stratégiques pour continuer à
aider l'Ukraine et ne conteste pas
l'effort nécessaire qu'engage la nation
en faveur de sa défense néanmoins au
regard de toutes les réserves exprimées
précédemment dans notre grande majorité
nous nous affinerons sur ce projet de
LPM merci merci chers collègues
la parole est à Monsieur Ludovic est
pour le groupe RDPI pour 5 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président
rapporteur mes chers collègues
j'aimerais tout d'abord si vous le
permettez associé à mes propos ma
collègue Nicole Duranton qui a travaillé
avec moi sur le sujet et également
adresser à un message à tous nos
militaires en cette veille de fête
nationale et du traditionnel défilé du
14 juillet et m'adresser directement à
eux afin de les remercier pour leur
altruisme leur professionnelisme et leur
abnégation à défendre quotidiennement
notre nation parfois au prix de leur vie
aujourd'hui s'achève le processus
législatif d'un texte éminemment
essentiel et fondateur pour nos armées
un texte qui sert la souveraineté de la
France et qui marquera notre politique
de défense pour les 7 prochaines années
dès 2017 le président de la République a
engagé une politique de rupture avec ses
prédécesseurs afin d'émettre un terme à
plusieurs décennies de diminution de nos
capacités militaires
en effet à l'heure où la grammaire de la
force sera refait son apparition dans
les relations internationales il était
essentiel que la France renoue avec la
grammaire de la puissance en
réinvestissant dans ses forces armées
ainsi dans le cadre de la LPM 2024 2030
il était essentiel que la France
continue de renforcer ses moyens avec
notamment le moyen de garantir son
autonomie stratégique assurer ses
engagements en tant qu'Ali de l'OTAN et
membre de l'Union européenne et être une
puissance d'équilibre après des années
de budget insuffisant les LPM 2019-2025
et 2024 2030 représente indubitablement
une remontée de l'effort de défense de
la France pour atteindre à l'horizon
2030 un modèle d'armée complet et
équilibré à ta répondre à l'ensemble des
menaces protéiformes auxquelles notre
nation devra faire face
à bien des égards elle place la France à
des défis majeurs qui l'oblige à
anticiper et à prévoir en effet avec la
LPM 2024 2030 la France passe d'une loi
de réparation à une noix de
transformation de nos capacités de
défense c'est une loi nécessaire pour
garantir un monde où l'exception
française prend tout son sens un monde
où l'excellence française doit reprendre
toute sa place
de plus cette LPM prévoit un effort
particulier sur un domaine que vous
connaissez bien monsieur le ministre les
outre-mer et notre groupe est évidemment
sensible à cette initiative en effet la
part outre-mer de cette loi de
programmation sera de 13 milliards
d'euros sur la période nos forces de
souveraineté bénéficieront d'un effort
généralisé sur le plan capacitaire
Corvette avion de transport drone génie
dual et constitueront un premier échelon
renforcé immédiatement disponible afin
de décourager toute tentative de
déstabilisation ou de prédation
j'aimerais ensuite saluer l'exemplarité
et la grande qualité des travaux menés
par nos deux chambres monsieur le
rapporteur
l'Assemblée nationale nous a transmis un
texte enrichi avec pertinence après deux
semaines d'examen et en ma qualité de
sénateur je souhaiterais remercier
l'ensemble de mes collègues du groupe de
la Commission et du Parlement tout
entier pour leur travail actif et
concret dans les différentes commissions
comment séances je pense que cette
navette parlementaire fera date par la
qualité des échanges tenus et par la
volonté permanente de trouver un
compromis
la Concorde et l'écoute ont été les
maître mot durant le travail final opéré
entre députés sénateurs au sein de la
commission mixparitaire les débats de
cette CMP se sont montrés passionnés
mais à la hauteur des enjeux et des
attentes de chacun
il n'en n'ont pas été moins cordiaux et
de qualité j'en profite également pour
saluer le dialogue constructif avec le
gouvernement et du particulièrement avec
notre ministre des Armées merci beaucoup
de nombreux points ont été débattus et
statués notamment à propos de la
trajectoire budgétaire la CMP a conclu à
une accélération des investissements sur
les quatre premières années la culture
du compromis inhérente activité
parlementaire a permis d'arriver un
accord concernant les augmentations
annuelles du budget de la défense il est
en effet été décidé que 2,3 milliards
d'euros de crédit initialement programmé
entre 2027 et 2030
reconfigureront de la manière suivante
avec 3,3 milliards pour 2024 2025 3,2
milliards pour 2026 et 2027 et 3,5
milliards pour 2028 est devenu 29
en définitif cette loi de programmation
militaire avec l'enrichissement du
Parlement envoie un signal clair celui
d'une France qui poursuit son effort de
rénovation mais aussi de transformation
de ces armées avec afin de répondre au
menaces grandissant dans un monde en
perpétuelle mutation celui d'une France
qui souhaite garantir son autonomie
stratégique celui d'une France qui
souhaite avancer sans interdire
d'ambitieux programme de coopération
notre groupe vaudra pour votre a pour ce
texte qui se traduit encore une fois par
une ambition sans précédent de briser
1960 et c'est pourquoi je vous invite
chers collègues à en faire de même pour
notre pays pour nos armées et pour notre
souveraineté il en va de la grandeur de
la France et un grand homme un grand
homme nous a appris qu'à cette fin une
seule attitude nous est permise il faut
viser haut et se tenir droit je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues
la parole est à Monsieur Rachid temal
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste
républicain pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur président également monsieur
le ministre je vais commencer par vous
dire que le groupe socialiste écologiste
et républicain votera avec satisfaction
et exigence la 15e loi de programmation
militaire ici de la commission mixte
paritaire
pourquoi d'abord parce que c'est vrai
plutôt certains ont saluer avant moi
cette loi de programmation militaire a
été je crois un exemple il serait bon
que d'autres mistes suivent cet
exemplaire de co-construction sur dans
les deux chambres mais je crois de débat
intense parfois notion c'est de les
dernières heures avant la commission
xperitaire mais en tout cas utile je
crois au pays et à nos armées pour un
nouveau truc également parce que il y a
aussi beaucoup d'apports certes issus du
Sénat mais je sais aussi porter par mon
groupe qui a été qui ont été ces apports
la repris par le Sénat et ensuite
conserver dans le texte de la commission
mixparitaire d'abord la définition des
principes des objectifs je crois que
c'était important que on commence dans
cette loi de programmation militaire par
dire pourquoi nous la faisons quels sont
les objectifs même si encore une fois il
était nécessaire et c'est le cas de
garder la souplesse nécessaire parce que
moi de programmation militaire sur
autant d'années peut aussi te ramener à
être évolué et à évoluer en fonction des
conflits des risques que nous pouvons
reconnaître deuxième chose sur la
question des finances nous avions dit
depuis le début que les 400 + 13 étaient
pour nous satisfaisants et donc je sais
que d'autres avaient d'autres points de
vue mais nous étions sur ce point-là
dire également que nous avions exigé que
la bosse ce qui est à effet un débat
lors de la précédente la programmation
militaire et celle-là a été annulée donc
c'est une bonne chose puisque le
ministre a accepté effectivement que 2,3
milliards soient passés de 27 30 à 24 27
en sachant que notre exigence et nous on
ne comptons de l'avoir c'est que la
somme supérieure un siège d'abord et
avant tout sur la question de
l'entraînement sur la question de la
fidélisation des postes et sur la
question de l'entretien du matériel je
crois des choses attendues et
nécessaires pour nos forces armées
dire également que nous avons été
satisfaits parce que il y a beaucoup de
choses qui vont qui va améliorer en tout
cas on l'espère la vie de nos troupes la
question indiciaire ou d'autres et je
crois que cela est aussi à saluer dire
également qu'il y a un élément important
quand on est parlementaire nous sommes
ici au Parlement sur la question du
contrôle parlementaire
surtout quand on sort d'une loi de
programmation militaire qui avait fait
j'ai envie de dire un peu la pas sur ce
point là et là nous avons effectivement
la nécessité l'obligation d'une d'un
bilan c'est une bonne chose je crois que
c'est nécessaire deuxième élément la
question du Livre blanc ou livre kaki
pour ceux qui préférons en tout cas le
fait que pour construire la prochaine
loi de programmation militaire il y aura
bien un débat parce que le lien
nationaux armé est important parce que
effectivement quand on voit le conflit
en Ukraine est important que la
population aussi entendent comprenne ce
que ceux qui aujourd'hui un risque comme
celui-ci et puis je reviens sur un
dernier point qui est la question dans
le contrôle parlementaire et je crois
contrairement aux collègues tout à
l'heure c'est un point historique
oui mon groupe a porté le fait qu'il y
ait une évaluation de toutes les
questions des ventes d'armes parce que
et nous sommes satisfaits aujourd'hui
que ça soit maintenu dans le texte sous
une forme d'une commission parlementaire
alors toujours pareil il y a ceux qui
veulent toujours plus il y a ceux qui
essayent en tout cas d'avoir des choses
efficaces parce que cette commission
permet de choses et pour mon groupe
c'est important de le dire à cet instant
d'abord nous soutenons l'industrie de
défense et nous souhaitons nous
effectivement que la France garde son
rang voire même progresse sur la
question de la production de la vente
d'armes à la fois pour nos troupes pour
notre sécurité mais en même temps parce
que c'est des soucis c'est des questions
d'export et en même temps nous
souhaitons que le débat démocratique de
s'arrête pas au moment où nous devons
parler de ces questions là je crois que
nous avons trouvé un bon compromis et
qui saura je crois historique parce que
c'est une première et je crois qu'il
faut le souligner donc pour ces points
là je l'ai dit nous voterons et puis
effectivement le ministre l'a rappelé je
crois qu'il sera important et le groupe
le fera nous l'avons fait sur la
question de la politique de la France en
Afrique et nous faisons effectivement
lors de la prochaine mandature des débat
notamment sur la question de l'OTAN
parce que nous l'avons dit on sait bien
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons une armée
complète et c'est une bonne chose à me
conventionnel dissuasion nucléaire et
nous souhaitons les deux mais il est
clair que maintenant la question de
qu'est-ce que nous faisons concrètement
plus en profondeur dans le temps
qu'est-ce qu'on met sous le vocable de
politique européenne de défense tout ça
est devant nous et on le voit bien il y
avait la question on le voit bien que le
sommet qui a eu à autant ces derniers
jours avec des décisions qui ont été
prises sur sur la question la défense
supplémentaire a apporté à nos amis
Ukrainiens voilà nous souhaitons
vraiment cela donc pour conclure encore
une fois moi je souhaite à nouveau
souligner le travail fait parler de
chambre ici bien sûr saluer le travail
du Président Cambon qui dans sa méthode
depuis plusieurs mois maintenant assu
associer l'ensemble des rapports
budgétaires mais l'ensemble des groupes
et je crois qu'il faut le souligner et
le saluer le remercier une nouvelle fois
également souligner ici la capacité
d'écoute de discussion j'ai envie de
dire à l'ancienne et ça nous satisfait
du ministre de des armées nous avons pu
au moins avoir un débat effectivement
toujours exigeant franc mais une fois
que nous sont d'accord on allait
jusqu'au bout je crois que c'est bien de
le rappeler et ça honore la fonction
effectivement et ministérielle je crois
législative que nous portons et puis
dire encore une fois que ce vote positif
parce que nous voulons saluer rendre
hommage encore une fois aux hommes et
aux femmes qui composent nos armées
composent l'armée à la fois dans les
opérations bien sûr extérieures bien sûr
aussi sur notre territoire et on sait
très bien que c'est un métier si
particulier qu'il donne parfois leur vie
pour notre pays et ce qui est le pays du
monde la France je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Monsieur Pierre Laurent pour le groupe
CRCE pour 5 minutes
je suis le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur c'est
donc au final un projet co-écrit par le
gouvernement et la droite sénatoriale
qui a été adopté en CMP le 10 juillet
les différents budgétaires affichés ici
même lors de l'examen du texte sont
envolés dans la nuit de dimanche à lundi
pour consacrer l'accélération de
l'augmentation des dépenses militaires
dès la prochaine loi de finance au
moment où Gabriel Attal annonce au nom
du gouvernement un serrage de vie sévère
de tous les budgets nationaux la LPM
garantit elle dès 2024 une augmentation
de 4,5 milliards d'euros de nos dépenses
militaires
48,5 milliards d'euros des 2024 de
budget 69 milliards d'euros à terme en
2030 413 milliards d'euros au total
auquel il faut ajouter les dépenses
militaires des OPEX et celles pour
l'Ukraine dépense qui vont durer le
sommet de l'OTAN vient de consacrer la
perspective d'une guerre longue et
coûteuse plutôt que celle de la
recherche d'un cesser le feu et de
négociation politique pour le retour à
la paix la LPM consacre donc de fait la
priorité guerrière au-dessus de toutes
les autres priorités nationales alors
même que les lignes les leçons des
dernières décennies nous enseignent que
l'escalade militaire mondiale actuelle
ne réduit pas l'insécurité collective
mais qu'elle en est un des facteurs
cette LPM s'inscrit en effet dans le
mouvement mondial pour le suramement la
militarisation des relations
internationales la militarisation de
tous les espaces communs qui devraient
être au contraire protégés comme des
biens communs des militariser
malgré l'augmentation très importante
des crédits des paradoxes vont demeurer
dans l'équipement de nos forces parce
que la LPM organise en fait la montée en
puissance dans deux directions
structurantes la dissuasion nucléaire
qui verra ses crédits augmenter de 54
milliards d'euros avec une grande
opacité sur les montants crédités dans
les différents programmes consacrés à
cette modernisation alors que cette
stratégie dissuasion est le socle censé
assurer la protection du territoire
national
aucun débat sérieux ne nous aura permis
de réévaluer cette stratégie de
dissuasion nucléaire dans une époque
pourtant propice à la reprise de la
prolifération la proposition que nous
faisions d'accéder au statut
d'observateur du Tian a été rejeté sans
ménagement quitte a suscité
l'incompréhension grandissante d'une
majorité d'États membres des Nations
Unies nous avons d'ailleurs passé plus
de temps à débattre de la tenue des
futurs réservistes qu'à cet enjeu
mondial il faudra sans doute y revenir
de même nous n'avons débattu ni de
l'initiative diplomatique française pour
la promotion de la paix du désarmement
multilatéral dit notre stratégie de
prévention des conflits cette absence
dans le débat d'ailleurs été concrétisé
par l'absence de celle de la ministre
des Affaires étrangères qui n'a jamais
assisté à nos débats la seconde
direction structurante de cette LPM
consacre le tournant d'une stratégie de
défense nationale vers une stratégie
militaire agressive totalement intégrée
au dispositif d'engagement de l'OTAN
l'évocation d'une autonomie stratégique
européenne est maintenue dans le texte
mais dans les faits cette perspective et
aujourd'hui écarté au profit d'une
stratégie purement hôtelienne le sommet
de l'OTAN de Vilnius vient de le
confirmer les Américains mènent le bal
ce sont eux qui ont annoncé l'accord
honteux avec la Turquie pour valider
l'entrée de la Suède dans l'OTAN en
marginalisant l'Europe dans cette
négociation ce sont eux qui fixent les
calendriers ou la montée en charge de la
stratégie Indo-Pacifique d'hostilité à
la Chine pour tenir sa place la France
en est réduite à jouer les bons élèves
au point que nous annonçons par exemple
que nous livrons à l'Ukraine des
missiles scalp au moment même où les
États-Unis décident unilatéralement de
livrer des armes à sous minutieux alors
que celle-ci sont bannies par la
Convention d'Oslo ratifiée par les
principales puissances européennes
pour vanter nos stratégies d'exportation
d'armement autre problème majeurs de la
LPM qui fait reposer le financement de
notre souveraineté industrielle sur un
modèle assis sur l'exportation
l'augmentation de ces ventes d'armes
nous faisons ainsi du Premier ministre
indien maudit l'invité donneur du 14
juillet après avoir reçu à l'Élysée il y
a quelques semaines Mohamed Ben Salman
c'est probablement ce que vous appelez
défendre le camp de la démocratie vous
l'aurez compris bien qu'attaché à une
solide défense pour notre nation
les raisons restent nombreuses pour
notre groupe de voter contre cette LPM
comme nous l'avons fait à l'Assemblée
nationale et ici au Sénat je vais
terminer par deux brèves remarques la
première pour souligner que la LPM
retient la proposition d'une commission
parlementaire chargé de travailleurs à
un contrôle des ventes d'armes de la
France c'est un sujet qui nous importe
même si nous considérons le périmètre
des prérogatives insuffisants à nos yeux
nous entendons agir pour y obtenir la
transparence qui fait aujourd'hui défaut
car nous refusons pour notre part depuis
toujours de considérer la vente d'art
comme une simple variable d'ajustement
de notre balance commerciale enfin le
texte adopté prévoit de nombreuses
étapes du contrôle parlementaire et nous
nous ont félicitons et nous entendons le
groupe CRCE continuera de participer
activement à toutes ces étapes de
contrôle parlementaire plusieurs
rapports annuels thématiques doivent
être rendues et débattus nous y verrons
des travaux complémentaires sont
annoncés sur des sujets importants nous
y veillerons aussi c'est notre état
d'esprit et c'est ainsi que à la fois
nouveau à l'encontre et à la fois nous
resterons impliqués totalement dans ce
débat merci merci chers collègues
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier
sigolotti pour le groupe Union centriste
pour 5 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et des forces armées mes chers
collègues les enjeux de cette loi de
programmation militaire sont
considérables il s'agit de préparer un
modèle pour nos armées à la mesure d'un
contexte international en profonde
mutation la nécessité de moderniser
aujourd'hui la troisième génération de
la dissuasion vient s'ajouter sur le
plan budgétaire à l'objectif de procéder
au renouvellement trop longtemps différé
d'équipement conventionnelle majeur sans
pour autant négliger les nouveaux défis
technologiques
nos débats ont démontré sur le fond que
la grande majorité des sénateurs partage
ambitions du gouvernement et salut ces
efforts afin de poursuivre le
redressement des capacités des armées et
d'en prévoir la transformation
cette loi de programmation répond au
temps que possible aux besoins
capacitaires et permettra en parallèle
des investissements importants dans le
spatial le cyber les drones et leur
enseignement elle prévoit également de
renforcer notre défense nationale en
renouvelant notre arsenal de dissuasion
nucléaire tant au niveau océanique
aérien a fait du conserver une capacité
à intervenir son maintien anniv à niveau
exige un budget substantiel dès la
prochaine dès la prochaine décennie j'en
profite pour évoquer les 5 milliards
dédiés à l'engagement du programme du
porte-avion de nouvelle génération le
Charles de Gaulle aura je l'espère son
successeur et les travaux qui seront
menés dans les 18 mois permettront
d'affiner son coût total
j'en viens maintenant au travail mené
par le Sénat tant en commission
cancéance travail qui a été salué pour
sa précision mais également pour sa
qualité le texte issu de la CMP reprend
d'ailleurs très largement la rédaction
du Sénat les apports de notre chambre
sont notables je pense par exemple au
renforcement des pouvoirs de contrôle du
Parlement sur la bonne exécution de la
LPM ainsi que son rôle dans
l'actualisation de la programmation à
l'accroissement des pouvoirs
d'information du Parlement et la
délégation parlementaire au
renseignement à l'introduction de plus
de souplesse dans les marchés publics de
défense et de sécurité ou encore à
l'adoption d'une trajectoire ambitieuse
de hausse des effectifs des volontaires
de la réserve opérationnelle
si des ajustements et compromis ont pu
faire consensus dans bien des domaines
les reports de charges et les marges
fonctionnelles monsieur le ministre ont
rendu parfois difficile nos discussions
la question centrale de la trajectoire
budgétaire est également resté un point
de désaccord majeur lié à des lectures
différentes sur un plan de technique
budgétaires les marches d'évolution
budgétaire très progressives repoussant
la plus forte hausse des dépenses après
2027 n'était pas acceptable au regard de
l'ambition affichée par cet LPM la
position de compromis adopter en
commission mix paritaire répond à la
principale demande du Sénat et nous
sommes très intéressantes en actant un
effort significatif sur les premières
années de programmation avec une hausse
de 3,3 milliards d'euros en 24 puis 25
et de 3,2 milliards en 26 puis 27 c'est
ajustement de la trajectoire qui permet
de répartir 2,3 milliards d'euros
d'augmentation supplémentaire sur la
période 2024-2027 est essentiel et très
attendu par nos armées notamment pour le
maintien en conditions opérationnelle du
matériel et pour la préparation
opérationnelle de nos forces monsieur le
ministre au-delà de ces aspects
financiers le travail collectif effectué
sur cette 14e loi de programmation
militaire envoie un signal très positif
aux armées en améliorant les conditions
de vie et de travail des personnels de
la Défense et de leur famille en
bonifiant les conditions des réservistes
et en renforçant notre économie de
défense et notre crédibilité stratégique
aussi le groupe de l'Union centrist
votre en faveur des conclusions de cette
commission mix paritaire votre en faveur
d'un texte ambitieux et majeur tant pour
la nation que pour nos armées enfin à la
veille de ce 14 juillet fête nationale
faite de la République et de ses valeurs
ayant une pensée pour tous ceux qui au
quotidien assurent notre sécurité assure
la protection de notre territoire de la
population et des intérêts français nos
militaires et nos forces de sécurité
intérieure les forces morales de la
France constitueront le thème de
l'édition 2023 du défilé militaire un
terme un thème central porté par toutes
les générations et particulièrement par
la jeunesse engagée opérationnelle ou
réserviste qui incarne le présent et
l'avenir de nos armées je vous remercie
merci chers collègues
conformément à l'article 42 alinéa 12
dérèglement je vais mettre au voile
l'ensemble du projet de loi dans la
rédaction résultant du texte élaboré par
la commission experitaire j'ai décidé
d'une demande de scrutin public par la
commission et le groupe socialiste sur
le texte élaboré par la CMP il va être
procédé au scrutin public dans les
conditions fixées par article 56 du
règlement le scrutin est ouvert
personnellement on a voté le scrutin
343 exprimé 330 pour 313 contre 17 le
Sénat a adopté
[Applaudissements]
voilà merci monsieur le ministre
je vais suspendre la séance quelques
instants afin de permettre à chacun de
s'installer pour le prochain point à
l'ordre du jour la séance est suspendue